well you want to hear the joke right
charlie
say daddy it looks like charlie may need
a little more than a good luck when it
comes time to watch back his sister's
video diaries
the duncans aren't as g-rated as we all
thought
good luck charlie was one of disney
channel's most hilarious shows
your stand-up comedian too yeah
everyone's always telling me how funny i
am
a dysfunctional family that just keeps
growing what more could we ask for
but what we probably didn't realize is
that a lot of the jokes we were laughing
at
may not have been exactly appropriate
for our 10 year old ears
we might not have fully understood these
jokes before but that's not a problem
now
we're here to take you down memory lane
and expose all of the inappropriateness
hidden in the series warning
this could ruin your childhood
bob i just want to be the best at what i
do the duncan family was always known
for their very close
sometimes too close family bond that
means they were always there for each
other
including their parents amy and bob in
the episode battle of the bands it was
no different
after amy spent the day trying out her
painting skills and sadly being rejected
by her kids and our teacher val
bob takes it upon himself to cheer her
up it's here that things get a bit
inappropriate after listing off many of
amy's endearing skills like being a mom
a wife and nurse he finishes with why
don't we put
charlie to bed and then you and i can
cuddle because you
are also the best at that and then leans
in for a kiss
in true amy duncan fashion she shushes
him with her paintbrush and says
i tired i don't know about you but
cuddle
definitely means like a code word for
something else maybe some more baby
making
this is time you're never gonna get back
these wild jokes didn't just stay in the
duncan family either
a lot of the time they were made with
guest stars in the episode team mom
gabe scores his first date with new girl
emma but he needs his dad's help
during their date in the movies bob and
emma's father tag along
and while sparks fly between the two
teens emma's father
also seems to have taken a strong liking
to bob when emma returns to gabe's house
to ask him out for ice cream her father
pops out behind her and tells bob
while it could have been nothing but
innocent fun foursome is still a strange
word to use in a family show
especially on the disney channel i hear
you bobsled
that's a cry for help the writers were
not afraid to add in these jokes with
the younger generations either
in the episode bob's boby gone amy
enlist gabe to watch their local news
channel in hopes that they'll catch her
pre-recorded segment
while waiting amy gets into the gossip
between the news anchors telling gabe
that
phil and ronda used to be a couple that
is until rhonda decided to give the
green grocer a squeeze
all we have to say is what is a green
grocer
and what exactly was she squeezing
there were also inappropriate jokes
sprinkled amongst the teens in the
episode the curious case of mr dabney
teddy becomes jealous when best friend
ivy starts texting amy
in order to get her back she invites
ivy's mom mary lou to her house to hang
out but
mary lou thinks that there's something
wrong with ivy when she gets to the
duncan's house
she asks teddy is ivy in trouble oh no
is she back on the chocolate as kids
most of us probably
brush this line aside as avi being
addicted to sweets
but mary lou's tone made it seem like a
serious matter
and the phrase chocolate has always been
used as a name for multiple illegal
substances
pj and teddy were always at odds and in
this case it was no different
pj picks up the guitar as his new talent
and forms a band with emmett but teddy
can't stand his constant strumming
confronting him in the basement she
unplugs his amp and says
about to come down here again this gets
plugged in somewhere else
we can only imagine what she meant by
somewhere else but the location probably
wasn't for a g-rated audience
they say that age is just a number when
it comes to love and apparently in good
luck charlie
the same applies to inappropriate jokes
during the episode it's a charlie duncan
thanksgiving
grandpa duncan pays his family a visit
but instead of spending time with his
grandkids
he gets cozy with their rival and next
door neighbor mrs dabney
after spending the afternoon together
the two return to the dunkin home where
they cuddle on the couch
mrs dabney puts on her best mysterious
voice and much to the disgust of gabe
and bob explains
after frank unclogged my disposal
he unclogged my heart i'm sorry what did
grandpa duncan unclog mrs dobney
our buying expert here didn't measure
doesn't need to know the detail
pj is well known for being the sibling
that just couldn't quite understand
everything that was happening around him
and in the episode special delivery
it led to a joke that probably wasn't
the greatest for younger viewers
the duncan family is frantically
preparing for the arrival of their fifth
child
that means bob and pj were tasked with
getting a new car you might think that
the moment bob drives the car into the
house is the most shocking part of the
episode but
do you remember this while talking to pj
bob refers to the new car as
she which gets pj extremely confused he
asks his father
does she [ __ ] tell before bob can
respond
pj drops to the ground to inspect the
underneath of the car
we can only assume that he was looking
for something that definitely wouldn't
otherwise be featured in a family show
now what would you say to that
this next good luck charlie episode
teddy on ice didn't just feature a
scandalous joke
the whole plot line just seemed a little
wild for a disney channel show
the duncan family struggles with a
toddler charlie who can't seem to stop
saying an apparently very bad swear word
although viewers never hear the word she
was repeating we do find out that she
did pick it up from amy herself
surprisingly enough the same plotline
was featured in an episode of modern
family
which is definitely meant for a much
older demographic
so did the goodluck charlie creators
take this episode a little too far
the duncans aren't exactly the calmest
of people and in the episode take mel
out to the ball game
viewers get to see firsthand that their
wildness spreads out more than just in
their immediate family
feeling bad for their uncle mel teddy
along with ivy decide to pick him up
from his retirement home and take him to
a baseball game
but we soon see that teddy definitely
should have listened to her parents
while at the game mel gets extremely
angry and pulls down his pants in the
stands
teddy and ivy luckily cover him up with
their large foam fingers to spare their
viewers from being traumatized but
having a character on a children's show
pulled down their pants just doesn't
seem like the smartest plan
did you notice that every time we kiss
balloons appear
in the episode can you keep a secret you
might think teddy was being a little
over dramatic when she found out that
acting as a princess at her new super
adventure park job would mean that she'd
have to kiss the frog
but when pj's best friend emmett breaks
the news to her he nods his head
and admits that he was involved with the
last princess
and she quit her job over it go ahead
charlie say it
we all know the real life struggle of
finding the best halloween costume and
apparently in the good luck charlie
world
teddy was having the same problem when
pj questions her costume choice
and calls her little bow peep in the
episode scary has a little lamb
she corrects him and says that the
little peep costume wasn't appropriate
there was not enough bow little too much
peep we feel for you teddy
oh nice to meet you i'm amy and this is
my daughter charlie
charlie brown while this next reference
is a little more tame
compared to some of good luck charlie's
jokes it definitely could erase some
eyebrows with parents of the viewers
in the episode quickie check amy's
competitive side comes out during a mom
and me type play session
she accuses a mother of naming her
daughter brittany after a troubled pop
star
she was comparing the toddler to britney
spears and her very controversial past
you named her after a troubled pop star
that wasn't even close to the end of it
for amy
in the episode charlie is two while
planning for charlie's second birthday
bob orders a miniature horse for the
party's entertainment when amy heads to
the garage to check out the horse
she begins petting it but suddenly stops
and asks why is his tail going up bob
and amy
quickly head out of the garage but not
before they shoot some startled looks at
one another
it leaves us wondering what tale amy was
exactly referring to ah
it's adorable how could we forget the
epic two-part episode of snow show where
the dunkins head up north
not listening to warning pj decides to
take on one of the ski resort's biggest
mountains
unsurprisingly he crashes and wakes up
in a cabin with two girls
not only are those girls eager to give
pj a bath but they also mention that
their father isn't home
in the end they're interrupted by the
girl's father but not before pj can take
off his robe to reveal his
naked underneath this is on par with
uncle mel
and if you drive i can play word jumble
on my cell phone
actually i do that anyway but this way
is legal charlie repeating her mom's
swear word wasn't the end of
inappropriate language in the series
during the episode driving mrs dabney
teddy after being rejected by her father
offers to drive her neighbor mrs dabney
wherever she wants
on their trip though mrs dabney gets a
serious case of road rage where teddy
says
oh look grandpa's telling us we're
number one when talking about the driver
in front of them
today it's clear that the grandpa was
definitely sticking up the middle finger
but what were our younger brains
thinking when we watched
that scene i know what he's doing
gabe was always in some kind of trouble
at school and in the episode duncan's
got talent
he was dealing with a very complicated
relationship status
his classmate joe let him know that
their relationship label was
complicated however gabe is confused and
starts telling joe about a dream he had
with her in it before he could go into
any detail he backtracks and says
what kind of dream were the writers
hinting at here why are we making such a
big deal out of this to bring a new baby
home like every six months
amy and bob's inability to stop having
kids was never brushed under the rug on
good luck charlie
instead it was constantly the butt of
the joke in the episode all fall down
bob accidentally releases termites in
their home and when he questions why
they're multiplying so fast
his co-worker gets a little cheeky and
replies well they are in the duncan
house
kind of a when in rome situation
amy and bob ran into some close calls
with gabe about the talk
and it led to some prime comedic moments
in the episode kitten caboodle
when gabe turns to amy for some girl
advice amy tells him about the beginning
of her relationship with bob saying
when your dad and i first started dating
we didn't do a lot of talking mostly we
just
and then after catching herself says
play checkers
ah there you go that explains all the
kids it's very romantic
honey you just interrupted me bob you
know your stories go on forever
pj's cabin incident on their ski trip
wasn't the only inappropriate thing to
happen
in the snow show episode after
announcing their family vacation
teddy thinks that they're surprising
them with another sibling amy quickly
jumps in and says that and i can assure
you we will not be making that
announcement ever again
but teddy with good reason make sure the
warning sticks with her dad by staring
at him
bob gets offended and says why you point
your finger at me having babies is a
team effort
with gabe questioning the conversation
by saying what do you mean
in the same episode amy and bob recount
their spontaneous wedding night where
they tell their children
you know the weekend we got married we
weren't even planning on doing it
getting married and then a few minutes
later say oh we did it
got married leaving gabe very confused
again
we were definitely all in gabe's boat
when it came to understanding these
scenes
back in 2011 haven't you had the talk
with him yet i haven't had to talk with
pj yet
i'm good i think it's safe to say that
charlie is going to get a whole lot more
than relationship advice when she hits
rewind on those video diaries
at this point it might be better for
charlie to not watch those videos
unless she's looking for some intense
embarrassment what do you think about
all the hidden adult jokes and good luck
charlie
do you think that the creators took it
too far for a disney channel show
let us know what you think in the
comments section below don't forget to
hit that subscribe button
and turn on the notifications so you can
stay up to date with everything on the
things
we'll see you next time wait a minute
i'm not done yet no but we are